alright movie review and town yeah we're
gonna go in today yeah we're doing
another 70s 100 house slash vampire yeah
vampire living in a haunted house
Salem's Lot yes from 1979 one of the
better Stephen King adaptations I have
to say it's from his second novel which
was published in 1975 originally
intended to be a feature film but I
guess after it was purchased by Warner
Brothers they thought you know they they
have like three different directors like
turning a screenplay and nobody can
really get it right so then they decided
well let's make it a miniseries because
you know the novel is so long and it's
so intricate yeah it came out on TV when
I was a kid and I remember watching it
and it was it's scary and it's good it's
a really good TV miniseries it seems to
be one event a lot of people of our
generation that were into horror movies
and stuff like that
remember staring the [ __ ] out of them
when they were kids I guess you were in
the right age at the right time and you
know the way it was shot was it was
pretty effective you know it was a it
was a series of it's time it looks like
a movie today from that time yeah when
you look at it now it's movie quality
yeah
from the 70s but yeah pretty cool well
and it was directed by tobe Hooper who
also did obviously famously did the
Texas Chainsaw Massacre and you know
that when they were putting those TV
mini-series together they specifically
wanted him to direct it because of the
Texas Chainsaw Massacre
even though since it was done for TV
there's no they couldn't do any gore
they couldn't do any nudity or really
any like super violence or anything like
that wrote around it but in a way I kind
of felt like that made it more effective
because it made it more atmospheric yeah
it feels a lot like something some kind
of stranger things if you like stranger
things you'd like this it's a very sick
yeah I mean well like I said he's I've
been white I've watched stranger things
like both seasons of it like you know
when they came out but then I kept
telling Tom about it and he's like yeah
I have to get around to watch that so I
finally got him to start watching it so
we're like in the middle of season here
because I told him I'm like presenting
yeah I'm like you will [ __ ] it when you
see like some of these houses and stuff
cuz I'm like oh my god I have that couch
oh yeah they have those dishes oh my god
I mean it's like it's weird because it's
all this [ __ ] that you didn't remember
yeah you can't forget about the way
things look yeah but don't watch these
old movies brings it back to ya now it
should be said that I mean Salem's Lot
this is it's very 70s yeah the main
character who's been Mears he's a writer
as a lot of Stephen King's characters
are you know write what you know
and he's returned to this town of
Salem's Lot actually Jerusalem's lot but
that's how you know it's shortened and
he's come back because he wants to write
about the Marston house which is like a
well known haunted house in the town
that he grew up in it's like a local
legend yeah now Ben Mears is played by
David soul who probably best known from
Starsky and Hutch yeah bit of a weird
casting I think yeah and and the role is
written for a much younger guy I think
because they're acting like teenagers
and the students working in his late 30s
early 40s
yeah we watched a couple of years ago
because I bought you the DVD for
Christmas like well yeah yeah before
it's available on DVD and I must say
that it's better than I would say better
than half of the Stephen King full
feature movies oh yeah yeah a lot of you
know it's long long it's three and a
half hours something like that you know
interestingly cuz we were watching last
night on the DVD and in the extras there
is a theatrical trailer and Tom was like
what the hell was that for
it turns out that while they were
shooting the miniseries at the same time
they were shooting extra scenes and more
violence and stuff like that for a
feature film that was going to be
released in Europe was it ever yes yeah
[Music]
it wasn't as good
oh you know like I said there's more
nudity in it there's more violence in it
a couple of the scenes are different a
couple of them are taken out because but
they shot it simultaneously like I said
I've heard it's not as good as
the long mini-series version but who
knows but yet 7 or 12 minutes but this
one is like three and a half hours yeah
yeah the transfer is decent but not
great you know you can't get a rave yeah
and it's still in the weird like the TV
aspect ratio like that you know you
can't get in a widescreen that I know of
so it would be nice if that if Warner
Brothers would do like a blu-ray release
of it because like I said this is a
movie that it seems like a lot of people
like a lot of horror kids a lot of
horror nerds like being or that around
my age remember this very fondly and
remember it creeping them out
yeah it's creepy and a lot of the scenes
in it are still very very creepy yeah
and a lot of horror movies rip things
off out of this movie
oh my but I mean to be honest you know
Stephen King wrote Salem's Lot it came
out in 1975 the book and he specifically
said that this was kind of like his
version of Dracula yeah it is Dracula
Caan it's very Dracula like the plot is
very similar it has the same kind of
thing where you know someone comes ahead
Richard Straker in Salem's Lot is kind
of like a Harker slash Renfield sort of
character where just like sort of like a
living person who's like the the face of
the vampire and he handles all the
vampires business yeah and he comes to
the town before to like kind of pave the
way and then the vampire arrives like in
a crate yeah you know Europe or whatever
assume that he's just a regular guy but
you find out later there's more to him
than meets the eye he's a vampire yeah
you'll see he's got some abilities but
yeah and like I said as the story goes
on and like the inhabitants of this town
start falling to this vampire plague
it's it's structured very much like
Dracula where you know where the whole
thing with with Lucy and then somebody
you know her kidnapping the baby and all
this other kind of stuff all that kind
of stuff is in here yeah and there's a
lot of stuff with reference to rats and
things of that nature
yeah you also have the thing where
nobody knows much about vampires nobody
has to kill this guy to kill a man but
you gotta look up books to fight figure
to kill a vampire this cracks me I'd
never heard of Dracula I don't think and
I think they did that in a lot of Hammer
movies too it seems like whenever
there's a vampire you know on the hunt
or whatever in the town nobody
immediately says sees the marks on the
necks and host event hey vampire let's
kill it with a steak or whatever because
everybody knows how to kill a vampire
then they had to go through the thing
where they teach the audience on about
vampires right
it wasn't too egregious and this one
though I really really like I'm gonna be
one thing if it was like some monster
that you'd never seen before
right but everybody in the [ __ ] world
knows what a vampire and knows how you
killed well I think how [ __ ] up the
movie would be if the main characters
might oh yeah yeah it was the vampire
okay yeah now that's another thing too
because I don't take care of those just
like Dracula member Dracula yeah we saw
this on that movie yeah it's funny
because yeah and I realized that I was
gonna say to that you really can't win
because you either go the route of duh
ever gonna it's kind of like The Walking
Dead we never call them zombies run
though everyone in the world would call
them zombies if that happened in real
life yeah they never seen the movie nine
Living Dead or anything yeah and it's
like they have to figure out oh you have
to shoot him in the head or you know
what I mean it's like a whole learning
curve that you shouldn't really have to
have but then if you try to go the other
direction and say oh well in this
universe everyone has seen the same
movies that the people watching this
have seen so they know how to kill
vampires or whatever then you're gonna
come across as being like ironic right
yeah you know what I mean this isn't
this turn out a lot like that book what
was it called Dracula yeah boy this
watch sure does seem like Dracula
doesn't then it would be too self
referential and I'm not sure I would
like that either so I'm not really sure
how you can solve that conundrum now but
yeah they did a good job they did it's
pretty low-key yeah I have to say that
like when the ship first started
happening you know the writer Ben Mears
and his friend who was a teacher that
taught him back in the day and he's you
know still there
his name's Jason I think and he seems
Matt in the book but for some reason
they changed his name to Jason Burke I
think his name is and they're pretty
much like you know don't call me crazy
but I'm pretty sure
make me a vampire he's like yeah I think
it might be and then they tried to tell
the other people in town and they're
like no and then they're like oh maybe
you know what I mean because at first
like the main doctor that's in the town
all these people start dying of these
weird ailments like oh they're getting
all weak and then they turn up in the
hospital and they you know don't have
blood and said oh it's pernicious anemia
would like sudden onset pernicious yeah
but I like that it was kind of realistic
because it's like you wouldn't jump to
vampires but it didn't take them that
long to jump to vampires it seems like a
pretty reasonable timeframe yeah and the
movie it's it's good because I don't
know it's kind of because I guess it was
originally aired in two parts I guess it
was aired in two to our parts you know
with commercials so that's why it's only
three something hours so when you watch
it all in one go it kind of almost seems
I don't know the pace of it seems
strange when I was watching it again
it's slow it is very slow like they're
drawing certain parts out yeah they do
have to draw things out I guess because
you know I mean which is kind of ironic
because they wanted to make it longer
because they say well this book is too
long to adapt to a you know
feature-length film but it does kind of
give the movie room to breathe like you
kind of give a fun time watching yeah
you kind of like get into the heads of
some of the characters and and there's
almost like a quality of I think even
Stephen King when he wrote the original
book he said I wanted to write something
that was like Dracula meets Peyton Place
so it's kind of like a small-town soap
opera right you know with vampires which
is about what this is Leia women fool
around on their husbands yeah there's a
lot of like subplots of the like this
darkness going on without that stuff
though this would be a 25 minute movie
yeah so you have to have all that stuff
from the book in there because they're
the vampire part of the plot that's
resolved pretty quickly it is yeah and I
had forgotten about that now one thing
that I kind of wish they would have done
now the book I read it many many years
ago but I remember that the book was you
know the the town is small yeah but the
book seemed like it was larger in scope
right you I mean you really got
sense of like all the townspeople you
know becoming vampires because that's
what would happen if a vampire moved
into your town like exponentially
everyone would turn into vampires
everywhere but this vampire cleans out
the whole town pretty much yeah
towards the end of it even the cops are
running and in the cop is played by the
guy who played fair and flat and we're
more Conan and he does a good job he's
pretty cool yeah there's all kind of
okay now I think here know that we're
talking about people in the cast like I
said David soul of Starsky and Hutch
plays the main character that Marik's
which like I said it's a little weird
but I can see how they wanted to I mean
because it's about vampires
you kind of need a character that's very
no-nonsense very everyman to make it
more believable right right so I think
they kind of did a good job with that
now his love interest in the movie is
played by Bonnie Bedelia now the weird
thing about this and I can't remember so
someone is someone that's read the book
more recently than I have please remind
me how old are Ben Mears and his love
interest Susan Norton supposed to be
because when they start having a
relationship there this movie yeah
they're parking out by the lake and then
yeah they're acting like what teenagers
whatever like he asks her to dinner
right and then so for their first date
they have dinner at her parents house
yeah she still lives right yeah which to
me seemed very weird and one okay he
asked her to dinner which to me would
imply I'm taking you to dinner taking
you somewhere to a restaurant work for a
biplanes that's not a cook or something
like that but then like when they showed
the date happening there at her parents
house having dinner with her and her
parents right and I'm like wow first day
that's not awkward at all and then they
get in the car and then they like go out
parking by the lake yeah and like her
dad is like constantly giving her [ __ ]
about hey you're later I'm like dude
she's 40 yeah
I never cease for me but I've read a lot
of King but I never read this book by
King I've only seen the movie yeah King
writes
she was probably supposed to be in her
mid-20s
right 20 supposin anybody and I think
he's just being his late twenties early
thirties although even if she was in her
mid 20s like your dad telling you hey
don't go out on a date with that guy
belong below keep down five know how
king is he's trying to ease to even try
to describe you know those country
people there and they're doing it like
it was back in the 50s you know struck
me as very strange yeah and yet again
they're far too old for that story that
they're the actors yeah that they're
like oh we're gonna well we're going to
the movies and we're gonna go dark out
by the lake we're gonna go sit by the
lake and have sex and I'm because you
can't sex in her house because she lives
in the like I like the Horner though
that they have in there I remembered him
yes yes the character of Mark Petrie
he's played by Lance Kerwin and this I
love this character because I mean what
I saw this when I was a kid I can relate
to that character murder because he
loves horror [ __ ] he's got like his he's
got this big huge room it's all painted
red and black just like our room is
that's it
and he's got all horror posters and he's
got masks and he just builds little
horror models and he's super into it and
his parents are just constantly giving
him [ __ ] about yeah when are you gonna
grow out of this [ __ ] I would be
supporting your ass me right don't
listen to your parents
yeah and I'm saying that is a 45 year
old no but I can relate to it and I love
the fact that because he's super into
horror and stuff like that when the
whole vampire thing starts to happen
yeah he's like oh I know exactly what
yeah they are gonna get a crucifix I
can't let the vampire in because you're
gonna fight them in and stuff like that
but um let's talk about some of the
well-remembered super creepy scenes that
are in this because I guess
the little kids coming through the women
yeah like I said really no gore not much
violence doesn't really need to go but
it didn't really know because the
atmosphere of it was so good it's good
enough and so many people have kind of
singled out the scene where the the
little boy I think his name is Danny
Glick think so comes to his he's all
vampire eyes and he comes like floating
to his brother's window and scratching
at the window to give you a little bit
you got the content it's like I said
it's a vampire I need to get invited
because that's the rug now that that
scene is super creepy yeah
also when when the guy goes down there
the grave remember when the vampire
vampire called him to the grave remember
yeah and he jumps down the girl yeah the
great bigger guy yes but interestingly
when they did like all the the vampire
kids like floating outside the windows
cuz remember we were talking last night
about how they filmed that and stuff
like that yeah yeah they what they did
was they hooked the kids to a boom crane
that sort of thing and then specifically
because they said we wanted to come
through the wood we didn't want you to
be able to see wires right it's a pole
behind yeah there was like a pole behind
it and they shot it in Reverse okay so
they pulled it so it would look creepier
because everything looks weird when you
run it backwards and then shoot it and
then show it forward so yeah they did
that and it really does have that weird
like otherworldly kind of finality oh I
want to talk too about the vampire in
this Kurt Barlow yeah now the character
that is in the miniseries is very
different than the character that was in
the original book in the book Barlow was
much more like a Dracula type character
he could talk he was in fact he was kind
of more like Straker was in the movie
like kind of a urbane sort of yeah Bela
Lugosi type character but when they were
adapting this and even some of the early
screenplays that they had for this they
had the vampire talking but the guy that
was producing it or the guy that was
some I think the guy that was producing
it he was like you know he's like in
this day and age and he's like
especially in the 70s like so many
vampire movies came out
sigh flange Ella Dracula came out Verna
Hertzog's not far too came out and stuff
like that and he's like we wanted to do
he's like how how would you make a
vampire talk and not be funny it's like
we can't do a voice like Bela Lugosi
that's done that would be laughable you
know you know we can't do something like
a demon like like Reagan and the
Exorcist like Crowley kind of voices
like that would just be stupid you and
be able to hear him he's like so we made
the decision that we're gonna do like a
throwback to count warlock from the
original not Scott - we're gonna do a
vampire that looks rodent-like and
doesn't talk right and I think that was
the absolute correct yeah it worked
it's a creepy looking vampire he's very
creepy that did look that dude looks in
some of shots he looks at a Rexach he's
been in a [ __ ] ton of other movies his
name is his arms just looked like
broomsticks skinny they were oh yeah his
name's Reggie Mulder and he's been in a
ton if he was in he was in an Alfred
Hitchcock movie man you knew too much
and he was in mark of the devil he was
in Burpo that crystal plumage he's a
real actor Dario Argento movie and so
yeah he was in a bunch of a Zoltan hound
of Dracula all kind of stuff so he his
makeup in this even though this is made
in 1979 it still looks kick-ass the eyes
look really good the the contacts that
the yellow that like glows and the teeth
they're like fangs but they're almost
like curved yeah like they're these
weird curved fangs and he's all blue and
he has a gross ass fingers dirty clothes
yes and really and I think too that it's
more effective to that they don't show
him that many times no like most of the
movie is kind of based around you know
the relationships between the characters
the other townspeople getting turned
into vampires you don't really even see
Kurt Barlow and to probably like three
quarters of the way through maybe
two-thirds of the way through something
you're not gonna
ocular lestat or anything this guy lives
in squalor dead animals in his house
it's nasty
right he lives in the Mersenne house
right which you know like I said it's
the town's haunted house all this kind
of horrible [ __ ] happened there and when
they go in it like near the end of the
movie like when there is a vampire it's
just disgusting it's like not livable
know that that was actually a set they
built now the house I was wondering
about this the Marston house I was like
now is that an actual house where they
filmed it it's in fun Dell they said it
is an actual house but it didn't look
exactly the way they wanted it so they
built a facade okay over the original
house I guess so it is a house but it
doesn't look exactly like that I guess
they just found one in a location that
they're likes that look similar to have
the hand they burned they burned a house
down and maybe it was just a facade but
look like they set that house on fire
yeah yeah I bought into it like a real
fire and the implication too is that
they not only burned down the house but
the whole town was supposed to burn down
yeah be purified yeah because they're
trying to put like I said it's
essentially just and really like the
original Bram Stoker Dracula novel
Dracula the character is kind of like a
plague metaphor yeah there's a lot of
Dracula and a lot of vampire stories are
you know there's the whole thing where
we just have to burn it all down and
start over
nothing was weird about this movie the
way it ended yeah ended in a way like
they were almost setting up a TV series
well they did make someone did make a
cordon quote sequel yeah but it didn't
really have much to do wrote the
original and I think they were actually
throwing around the idea of doing a
series with Ben Mears and Mark Petrie
like vampire hunter yes like you know on
the run from the Salem's Lot vampires
are on the run from run wicked will be
you know yeah so cuz it was set up
perfectly for that for series now it
should be noted too that they made
another TV mini-series of Salem's Lot in
2004 you heard rumors oh and Rob Lowe
was in it really I'm gonna have to see
that [ __ ] I haven't seen it I've heard
it was not good okay but but you know I
don't know no it my stomach will do
the TV the TV version of The Shining I
like the TV version I didn't I mean it
wasn't us I mean it was a very different
movie there's a very different story
from what you saw in Kubrick's well yeah
yes
but the television version of The
Shining was right out of the book it was
real close to the book yeah it was well
like I said it was that wasn't a book
that wasn't that book wasn't moveable if
you were gonna make a movie out of that
book it would be beauty Kubrick's that's
how you do this no the reason that I
didn't like The Shining miniseries was
because it was exactly like the second
the book is fantastic Kubrick's movie is
fantastic they're two different animals
yeah and I don't really think that you
can take the story exactly a Stephen
King groaning camicus make a scary movie
out of it it's a stereo the viewer knows
too much about what's going on and it's
not scary
yes Gary Reed that was the biggest
problem that you know and I think I went
into this on my blog because I weren't
like a big long thing because we've
recently rewatched the miniseries and I
was kind of like the problem is you know
in a book you need a [ __ ] ton of
exposition because you're trying to
create a whole world the readers head
they're not they don't see anything so
you're trying to get them to imagine it
but in a movie just as little exposition
as you can get away with and I feel like
that's what he did wrong in the movie
adaptations like you know it's a movie
they're just pictures you know you know
you don't need to have somebody going
and then this bad thing happen and that
bad thing happened and this other bad
thing happened it's like yeah okay can
we just like leave that the cool thing
about Kubrick's versions they didn't
explain any that [ __ ] that [ __ ] happened
and it's like what is that we don't know
but now they didn't know but now we're
going on the shine yeah yeah well oh and
I was gonna say one of the other super
creepy scenes I thought was when's the
one got when the gravedigger guy gets
turned into a vampire and he's in like
the doctor's house or whatever and then
he dies and then they take him away to
the morgue or whatever and he comes back
to that dudes house I was
just sitting there in the rocking chairs
can eyes glowing oh it's like that is
creepy as hell but you can get this on
DVD
probably yeah only a couple bucks
depending on where you find it yeah I
think I bought it one or two years ago
and I think it was $10 we couldn't find
a place where you could rent an online
stream of it you know like I said it
seems like it kind of got abandoned yeah
even though maybe because it was made
for TV and I feel like a lot of
made-for-tv stuff doesn't really get a
lot of the appreciation it deserves even
there was some really good status TV
back then yeah this is better than some
of the movies of the day oh yeah
definitely and is worth watching I
recommend it definitely in the top 10
Stephen King adaptations maybe even top
five yeah I mean I can't you know that
I'm on the spot it was good this is URI
yeah this is in there they'll stand by
me yeah okay maybe cuz I'm gonna say I'm
thinking of more Dolores Claiborne yeah
but yeah I'm Gerald Kaye so yeah it'll
be top ten but like I said
now if younger people are watching it
now like I said it's it's slow-moving
it's kind of dated it's very 70s
everyone has feathered hair and bigger
collars and and velour yes sexy velour
jumpsuit sure whatever that was that she
was wearing right but that's all kind of
coming back around that's coming back
into vogue in the horse yeah so yeah so
I guess it wouldn't be strangers showing
stranger things
well any models like I said a lot of the
newer horror movies that came out that
were set back in the 70s and 80s so
maybe it's not as jarring for younger
audiences to see you won't have to worry
about CG or Okies jump-scares no there's
really not there's a couple of jump
scares but they're very effective yeah
it's very restrained especially
considering that it's tobe Hooper for
heaven's sakes the very atmospheric
but yeah it's you really kind of get
it's very mesmerizing that's the word I
want to use it's like you can just sit
there and like chill for like three
three-and-a-half hours and just kind of
get into this little town and the
snoozeshade about oh and one other thing
I wanted to mention too and I think they
didn't really go a few
I'm out into the haunted house aspect
yeah because I think the implication and
I can't remember what the implication
was from the book but I think the
implication from the movie was that the
house was an evil house right
because Ben mares the writer his whole
thing he came back to town because he
wanted to write a book about this house
because he thought the house was
inherently evil or he wanted to see if a
house could be inherently evil and so
his theory was that a house being
inherently evil would attract evil
people yeah so he's talking about all
the murders that happened there and all
this other stuff is gone yeah and he
talked about like a horrible experience
he had there as a child which made the
house you know made the house have a
huge impact on his childhood and why he
wanted to write about it so he's kind of
saying that you know the vampire is not
from that town he just came there
because he was attracted by the evil of
this house house that's kind of cool
angle which is kind of a cool angle and
like I said I'm not sure um you know how
that played out of the book I could
because it's been so long since I've
read it and the interesting thing too in
the movie and I'm pretty sure that's in
the book too
where he tells where Ben Mayer's tells
Jason Birk about the how he went in the
house when he was a kid he snuck in
there on a dare and he said he saw a
ghost like the ghost of Phoebe Marston
who was a gangster who used to live
there and killed a bunch of people and
it hung himself in there and he said he
saw a ghost of him like hanging and he
was all green and his eyes are all
popping out and stuff like that
now Stephen King said in his book Danse
Macabre that he based that image on a
recurring nightmare that he had as a
child that he went into a house and saw
a dude hanging yeah and he said he saw
the back of him and the dude like turned
around and he was wearing a sign around
his neck but he said that the person
hanging was him Wow he said and but he
said his eyes were all plucked out and
everything like that but he's like I
knew it was me and he's like it
image really bothered me a lot and he'd
had that trip a lot so he put it into
Salem's Lot so you know that's a little
interesting thing tonight and I do
recommend you read Danse Macabre because
I I read that book until I have a
paperback version of it and it has
fallen apart and that's actually one of
my favorite Stephen King books at the on
fiction but yes so that will do it for
our review of Salem's Lot check it out
if you haven't already it's a really
good a really good vampire film and I'm
not super into vampire films know what
I'm saying you know and like I said it's
kind of cool and an Oscar ah to his 70s
knots for a rod to your type away so if
you liked the show remember to Like
share subscribe check us out on patreon
or on our blog and contribute by a
paypal if you would like to do that and
tune in for our regular shows which are
posted every Tuesday and we will see you
next